project-based now has a CGI trailer
gameplay footage impressions from a 30
minute demo and most importantly a name
let's talk about blood-borne and let's
start with the gameplay
according to Massa Akiyama gawe from
japan studios the combat in blood-borne
is based on intense life-threatening
battles think about how you fight in the
souls games you're encouraged to take
out enemies methodically but you're also
encouraged towards a passive sort of
block weight and attack when the enemy
is open style of combat you probe for
weaknesses and you exploit them
blood-borne is taking the strategic
element from the soul series but
applying it in a different way in
blood-borne there's going to be a
transition to a quicker more offensive
and active combat style with close range
weapons and guns in the soul series
you're tentatively exploring the level
to make it through but in blood-borne
we've been told that we'll be under a
more constant threat and attack with
every fight being a scrap to survive in
this game it sounds like it will be
preferable to take out enemies quickly
before you can get overwhelmed an
offensive approach to combat rather than
the defensive one we see in souls games
that sounds really good in terms of
story blood-borne takes place in yharnam
an ancient forgotten city cursed with a
horrible endemic illness in light of the
name blood-borne it seems very much
inspired by the era of the Black Plague
except this illness it's a little
different rumors flying around suggest
that the blood-borne plague is turning
men into beasts another rumor is that
you become more beasts like as you take
the blood of your enemies which could be
some sort of twist on the hollow human
form mechanic over the years many
hopeless and afflicted people have made
pilgrimages to Yanam in search of a cure
you are one of these travelers
navigating this gothic horrific City
fighting off the endless deranged
nightmarish creatures that creep from
the shadows we've only seen one
protagonist so far but it's just like
the other Souls games you know there's
always that one character who is a
symbol of that game because according to
firm itsu character customization is
confirmed in the same article they note
that it's going to be very similar
mechanically to a Souls game with the UI
apparently more or less identical to the
Souls UI at this point there will also
be online elements and a few in
have also mentioned that a four-player
co-op is an emphasis of this game
perhaps being more play with a friend
friendly than previous titles in a
previous screenshot we saw blood flying
through the air in a manner reminiscent
of a soul in the later video footage the
protag was becoming more and more
drenched in blood and finally in the new
trailer the protagonist is cutting a
beast purposefully with his saw cleaver
there's this emphasis on blood and I'm
sure it'll play into the game
mechanically somehow just like we had
souls before this might mean that we
gain something from blood and to think
when we heard that Miyazaki was being
moved to a different project he said
that he wanted to work on a lighter
hearted game I think he might have been
messing with us permits who notes that
the game has been in development since
the release of the artorias of the abyss
DLC another interesting thing to note is
that we haven't seen any of the footage
from the gameplay leaked a little while
ago but a 30 minute gameplay preview was
shown behind closed doors at e3 and I
have the details for you here as I
mentioned before the game takes place
inside a city environments will be
densely layer as we dash through
alleyways across rooftops within houses
ascending stairs and Criss crossing
through adjoining rooms many paths will
be available and many will lead to the
same point so I imagine if you were a
fan of the complex level design in Dark
Souls where levels twist around on each
other and it sounds like you're going to
be a fan of this and as I thought about
the close-range combat that will take
place inside houses it reminded me of
the so clever we've seen within footage
so far the ability to transform it into
a close-range weapon or a long-range
weapon will really help you depending on
whether you're fighting in a closed
corridor or in an open courtyard for
example we've also been told that we
should expect to see an entire class of
transforming weapons as well these
weapons will have different properties
depending on the form they take for
example the soul Cleaver will be able to
crush enemy guards in its shortened form
they should add a really good layer of
depth and versatility to the combat you
might also be wondering about guns and
another surprising thing that we learned
was that guns are actually intended to
be more commonly a close-range weapon
that will help you the offensive
versatility
really what a lot of this has been about
it's been about giving you this
offensive versatility that will allow
you to cut down enemies more effectively
in one of the gameplay previews a player
was shown stunning an enemy with a
gunshot and then performing a finishing
critical attack Miyazaki has apparently
said that you cannot play this game the
same way you would play demon souls you
can't just stand back and bait enemies
until they're open no in this game you
have to take a more active approach to
combat or you risk getting overwhelmed
by a more constant assault so think
about it you actually have to cut down
enemies before they overwhelm you
because it sounds like they might be
coming at you at a more constant rate
keeping this in mind it makes sense that
we should be holding a gun in our
offhand instead of a shield and I can
see this shield 'less offense focused
shift being the biggest difference
between the Soul series and blood-borne
the main enemy in yharnam are the humans
turned beasts by the infection plaguing
the place but that's not all you should
expect to see in the footage enemies
were said to be hiding in the shadows
ready to jump out at you and join the
assault of other enemies a viewer
described mutilated crow like enemies
hopping towards the player and there's
this abundance of lycanthropes and
beasts seen so far the difficulty is
said to be similar to Demon Souls and
Miyazaki says to expect the same
satisfying feeling you get from
overcoming adversity in a Souls game to
me
the discussion is less about difficulty
and more about the different flavors
strategic gameplay we'll be seeing and
I'm really curious to see how well
faster paced combat will be developed
within the framework of a Souls game
blood-borne is being targeted for a
spring release in 2015 exclusive to the
PlayStation 4 platform it's exclusive
because Sony owns the demon souls IP and
actually co-developed this with From
Software and their own Sony Japan
studios similar to what they did back in
the day when they helped create Demon
Souls the team is aiming to get the game
at 30 frames per second at 1080p I've
listed a lot of sources in the
description and I really want you to
check them out to support the people who
translated articles and attended these
behind-the-scenes events subscribe to
hear more about blood-borne news when it
drops
you guys next time